we're here with the amazing gloria
estefan and joining us
now is her daughter emily and her niece
lily
hi you guys hi
girls good morning good morning
and by the way i love your yellow table
thank you it's an honor of you
no it's a table of hope hope yellow is a
hopeful color right lily and
that's what with the show we we want
people to feel
like uh they're a part of our family and
have us come into their family because
we want more connection beyond the one
that we've already made through our
careers
i'm so interested in how you parent
and what the relationship is like you
know with that journey and then also
what you're you know like emily what
your journey is because
i have to check my own ego all the time
as a parent and realize that i'm on my
children's journey
and so there's just so many dynamics
that go on within
you know a couple females in a family
i'm just dying for this show
i think it's unique because i have to be
honest and we talk about this on the
show as well we're a very privileged
family you know
my family sacrificed a lot my grandma's
phd was ripped in front of her face in
cuba
lilly didn't speak english so she did
the entire syllabus
for her school here in one day thinking
that it was one assignment and she did
the whole syllabus
you know like my family has sacrificed
for us to be able to sit there at that
table
so i just want to be there for young
kids
and anybody that's watching and show
them that like you said it is possible
to have these conversations my mom and
lily and i don't always agree or get
along
and that's okay but we come from a place
um of respect
and we try to talk and that's what it is
i hope that everybody grabs a table
whatever color yellow purple rainbow
sand table whatever just a safe space
you meet with your family
and talk that's what i'm excited for i
love that you say we come from so much
privilege i'm always acknowledging that
i you know i grew up in a lot of
different extremes so i've seen
a lot of different aspects and sides to
life
and i'm i'm just so excited for this
and i'm i'm so excited for the
conveyance of speaking with your family
and putting it all out on the table pun
intended and literally
this is just so excited do you guys mind
if i ask you a couple quick questions
that
i think came up on the show which i'm so
excited about
what age should kids be allowed to date
oh my god oh my god i
went i i confess i win on my son's first
date
i love this with him he was in fifth
grade
and he wanted to ask an older girl to
the movies
and i didn't want to tell them no and
then emily never dated
so i or at least i didn't know
that she was like how do i get my mom to
not come on this
date i'm just not gonna tell you thank
god or else you would have been on all
my dates
okay i have to have a boy lorenzo is 21
lina is 18 now but they
started yeah they dated when they were i
want to say 15
is that the right age i want to say 15.
yeah
i definitely feel like i want to greet
my daughter's first date with an
nda a chastity belt and a numerous
numerous paraphernalia that is
completely intimidating and this person
should
know that i'm either accompanying them
or if
one wrong move happens um
lily have you ever checked your
partner's phone not but i should
i've never ever checked my kids phone or
my ex-husband's phone i should have
no you know what though i i think that
karma
will come back on you for being a person
of grace
and i remember i was i think 16 i was
living with a boyfriend and i oh god
this is so embarrassing
he had a trunk and he was like this is
my private trunk and i
of course waited one day for him to
leave the house and i opened the trunk
and i went through it and i thought this
is the worst thing i've ever done i will
never do this to a human being again
when someone says please respect my
privacy respect
me so i'm with you lily what was in the
trunk
a lot of pictures of an old girlfriend
actually i was like maybe you two
should be together um okay this one's
interesting
because it's such a new what age should
kids be allowed to have a social media
account this is like
untested uncharted waters that's a very
good question and i don't know if i know
the answer or
even have one i think we're still trying
to figure out where social media fits
into the world
my big problem is the imbalance and the
fact that our lives are pinpointed to a
screen
it's taking over our lives you don't
want to eat the food you want to take a
picture you don't want to listen to the
concert you want to get the right video
i think over time we're going to find
that this actually has
a negative influence on our actual
neurons but for now i would say
if you have i mean i don't have a child
but if they were old enough i would
closely monitor it
and like severely limit the time that
they would have on social media it
scares me a lot and i'm not a parent i'm
just speaking as a millennial you know
and it scares me because
i've caught myself like why am i on my
phone right now you know it's like scary
emily i love the way that you speak
about
how the balance we need to be present
and not just experiencing life through a
portal
to stop to be present to make a table
literally or metaphorically to slow down
and discuss
life and how we all conduct it and
navigate it
i think what you're doing is important
and it's necessary
and we are all going to be cheering you
on and hanging on every word and
watching every episode
and thank you so much for letting me
have a seat at your table
with your family today i am hopefully
one day you can come to the real table
i would you i would give anything i
didn't want to invite myself but
i would i mean are you i think
perfect i think you can see how serious
i am about this
cross for a second season hopefully
people will love
what they see and they'll want more so
everybody
fingers crossed we are here rooting you
guys on because like i said this is
necessary
right now and just thank you so much for
letting me have a seat at this table
today red table talk with the estefans
episode one available now and episode
two will premiere tomorrow on facebook
watch the latest album brazil
305 i know that's the miami area code oh
yeah
um and um thank you guys so much
for being a part of this show
[Music]